foodwatch hat gerade nochmal coca cola
an den pranger gestellt weil die sich
mit einem eigenen youtube kanal direkt
an kinder und jugendliche wenden
so sieht das dann aus dass ganz toller
vorspann mit cola der mega hit bei
youtube mit cola super verfolgungsjagd
natürlich mit cola hammerharter parcours
mit cola dann einfach mal cola und dann
noch ein cooles foto mit cola so kriegst
du die kids youtube und jetzt will der
konzern auch noch an senioren run habe
ich gehört
der neueste influenza bei cola tv ist
kein geringerer als ulrich von heesen
golf ist rege herzlich willkommen zu
katv dem objektiven gesundheit feiern
sie cola das ist viel mehr als ein
getränk das ist lifestyle dass es fahren
das ist todessehnsucht hier geht es
nämlich nicht um werbung geht es um
information und lasst euch nicht kirre
machen von irgendwelchen gesundheits
nazis ihr wisst doch selber was euch am
besten schmeckt haben irgendwas
probieren das schmeckt wie kläranlage
ganz hinten und kein mensch sagt man
soll nur cola trinken
das wäre unverantwortlich war wo ist
natürlich zwischendurch auch mal eine
schöne vertreten ich sitze sie heute mit
meinen halten homies dem marvin und dem
rang der marvin der gerade 30 dosen cola
getrunken und es gehe neben super joker
kommando verhallt diese geniale vetters
brause ist eine allzweckwaffe
damit kannst du alles machen villen sind
sich deiner enkelin auflösen oder das
reinigen unabhängige forschungen des
cola instituts in atlanta haben sogar
bewiesen sie ist auch ein hervorragendes
potenzmittel so leute genug gezählt der
marien der hang und ich wir machen jetzt
noch ne coole runde parcours
[Musik]
verdammte scheiße osteoporose das kommt
von diesem scheiß zucker hinzufügten
[Applaus]